paciente con cáncer esta cocina solar le
ha salvado la vida
Gracias a ella pudo dejar de usar leña y
carbón productos que le irritan e
inflaman los pulmones
me protege de otros problemas de salud
porque no tiene humo y no tengo ninguna
afección de salud causada por el humo
según un diagnóstico reciente Se podrían
salvar medio millón de Vidas al año en
el África subsahariana si se encontraran
alternativas a la leña tradicional en
las Américas el cáncer es la segunda
causa más frecuente de morbilidad y
Muerte en Uruguay los decesos por cáncer
representan el 25% y anualmente se
registran en promedio 17.000
diagnósticos la intendencia de
Montevideo se sumó a la conmemoración
del Día Mundial contra el cáncer con una
jornada detección gratuita los pacientes
con cáncer de países con bajos ingresos
normalmente no pueden acceder a
tratamientos efectivos la Organización
Mundial de la Salud tuiteó sobre la
inequidad a nivel mundial en la atención
médica de esta enfermedad
la falta de acceso a la atención contra
el cáncer reflejan las desigualdades e
inequidades de nuestro mundo el
tratamiento integral está disponible más
del 90% de los países de altos ingresos
pero en los países de bajos ingresos en
menos del 15% en el continente americano
los diagnósticos más frecuentes son el
cáncer de próstata de pulmón de cuello
uterino y gástrico